I really don't put an emphasis on how I
look but Eva Mendes does have a Beauty
secret that keeps her looking flawless
every time we see her shaving her face
[Music]
Eva sharing this video on Instagram with
the caption yes I shaved my face going
under the knife blade at Beauty Villa
Vergara in Beverly Hills
[Music]
a new kind of any kind of facial
treatment any kind of appeal a um radio
frequency treatment I like that stuff
[Music]
this procedure is called dermaplaning
first a scalpel exfoliates skin and
removes fuzz followed by a diamond peel
another non-invasive exfoliation
treatment Ava jokes I'm a beast so I
probably need every other day and I have
a theory if it hurts it's gonna have
better results and even knows what works
for her besting up in the comments
section makeup and moisturizer goes on
much smoother I'm hairy though my Cuban
poppy is a man bear and I'm his Mini-Me
yes exactly and there's a celeb
connection to her doctor that's Mariana
Vergara Sophia Vergara's cousin Sofia
was Mariana always the beauty Guru in
the family I mean are you texting her
all the time asking her questions well
not at the beginning when she was young
she was kind of like a tomboy and then
she went to medical school and we never
thought that she was gonna go into that
area so here we are and you know I think
it's well deserved the big question now
is is Mariana helping Ava get ready for
a Hollywood return she's put acting on
the back burner it's been almost a
decade since she last made a movie you
like that stuff
torture having instead focused on
business deals and motherhood she's mom
to Esmeralda and Amada her daughters
with Ryan Gosling acting is something
that you know I will always love it's
just like now that I have children I'm
kind of extreme there's just so many
things I won't do
like I won't do most of the movies I've
done in the past it was also shied away
from the red carpet and seemingly won't
be back anytime soon she recently shut
down fans asking if she'd be Ryan's date
to the big Barbie Premiere oh you should
stop by so cool her answer we don't do
these things together well red carpets
my God I haven't done red carpets in so
long and um I kind of you know by the
way oh that's very sweet I don't miss
you
and I say that with all the love in the
world
you as in the general you know yes yes
of course you I miss your face your
beautiful face but uh they're stressful
and I'm just you know I don't know I
just feel like you know if I can skip
one uh I do